from Sports Illustrated our buddy Chris
Mannix back here how are you Chris
what's going on rich another way it will
always works you know I'm gonna write
about the great hot start for the Lakers
and then they're gonna lose their next
game it's just the way it works in our
business in the Honda inside a rapport
with Chris Maddox right here what do you
make of the Lakers so far right now
Chris I mean they're regardless of what
happened in Indiana they are well ahead
of virtually everyone's expectations I
mean there are things with the Lakers
that should have expected I mean Anthony
Davis looking like the MVP that he has
played like the last few years is to be
expected
LeBron continues to be an offensive
juggernaut is expected but they've
succeeded because of so many things you
didn't expect LeBron being a two-way
player really for the first time since
he played in Miami frank vogel being the
right man at the right time for that job
and really pushing all the right buttons
the supporting cast that robbed lenka
put together no one of the stats I look
at with the Lakers that's really
impressive is the fact they're in the
upper half of the NBA three-point team
may have been as high as fifth in some
of the numbers I looked at recently in
three-point shooting if they finish the
season rich as a top five three-point
shooting team it's a wrap nobody's going
to beat them because if you can space
the floor with those two monsters out
there in LeBron and AD you're going to
beat everybody so there's just there's
no way you could have foreseen this team
being this good well you knew that
LeBron was hearing criticisms etc when
he's been tweeting out as you point out
in your column the hashtag of washed
King and using that as fuel for his fire
but do you think the fact that he is as
you pointed out a dynamite two-way
player for the first time since Miami is
the fact that he actually took April May
and June off for the first time in a
long time do you think that has
something to do with it
I think that's a big part of it I mean
point out the amount of rest he's
received this past off see
is you know it's virtually unprecedented
for him it really ever since like oh
seven he was playing in Conference
Finals and beyond so throw in the
Olympic cycles he's been a part of and
he's been constantly on the go so I
think that's definitely part of it I do
think in you know I wrote something
early in the season on LeBrons
relationship with coaches with Frank
Vogel in particular I do think that
there's a sense of urgency and LeBron to
take advantage of opportunities when
they present themselves and you know
this is an opportunity we know what the
NBA looks like it's wide open for the
first time in a long time the era of the
three star teams is basically over at
least for now
the windows there and I think coming
into the season LeBron saw that and
realize that he could as a two-way
player really propelled this team to to
RIT even higher level and I think that's
played a significant role as well well
with with Milwaukee having lost to the
Mavs the other night both teams coming
in off of a loss at 24 and four and the
big game coming up on Thursday night
what do you think we will learn from
that Bucks Lakers game Chris well I mean
I think it's a bar for both these teams
I do think that the Lakers have a sense
to get even better this season once Kyle
Kuzma kind of finds his way in the
rotation then one of the few guys on
that team that struggling and I think
the Bucks are still trying to find their
way with somebody in that committee of
wing players to replace Malcolm Brogdon
they're still looking for that but
there's no question for a young team
like Milwaukee that got beat in the
conference finals last year even though
they're at home if they can find a way
to beat this Lakers team that's gonna be
a big confidence boost for that group
and you know more than the Lakers
there's a greater sense of urgency in
Milwaukee I mean I would be surprised to
them to be among more active teams
before the trade deadline to try to find
some way to get better on the perimeter
because this summer is everything for
them
I mean Yanis is going to get that
opportunity to sign that Super Max
extense and if you press it down
it's over they'd have to trade him and
everything would kind of come crashing
down in there walking so I think they're
from Milwaukee in a game like this in a
season like this the sense where they
can't be higher so do you think that
they will have to win this year in order
to get Yanis to sign that Super Max you
think that that is absolutely the only
path to keeping you honest I don't know
Campion I do think that the only way
they can feel comfortable is if they get
to the finals because this we know what
the Eastern Conference looks like it's
it's it's as clear a path as it had in a
long time I mean Philadelphia better
need some shooting if there could be a
true threat to get to the finals Boston
I think is really flawed in that front
corner Milwaukee is really big in their
front court this is the year so if they
don't get to the finals and they lose
like a second-round to one of those top
to your East teams I don't think it goes
well for them so I think it's not slap
you trip or bust I think in Milwaukee
but if I had to guess I would say it's
final for us Chris Mannix is Sports
Illustrated in the Honda inside a report
let's stick on the Sixers there a little
bit Charles takes his shots on the
Sixers and embiid when he gets his
chance he's gonna be on Friday show with
my wife Susie Schuster and Marshall
Faulk sitting in and it'll be an
interesting conversation then what what
what are the holes that you think about
the Sixers that might prevent them from
getting to the promised land Chris it
starts with prim Tooting a loss to G
erratic and he was there lowly
consistent between if you turned they
haven't really replaced him I mean it
had guys have good games and Tobias
Harris is a pretty good three-point
shooter but Josh Richardson is there for
his defense and Ben Simmons even though
he's made a couple this year is still an
on threat from beyond the three-point
line I think that's one somebody whether
it's out of the you know the Bible
Harris you know combination in that
backcourt you know Brett Brown send
himself he's got a basically
manufacturer shooter out of that group
and that hasn't happened up until this
point and the other thing that that I
watched a lot of Sixers games and you're
still waiting to see Ben Simmons as the
guy that could
take over in the fourth quarter as Jimmy
Butler did somebody wrote this recently
I apologize not remembering but the
Sixers this year without Jimmy Butler
are like in the fourth quarter their
offensive efficiency is at the bottom of
the NBA and with Jimmy Butler last year
they were in the top ten in the NBA and
that's that's a significant number that
to me says that they found a way to
replace a guy that took over games and
scored for them late in the fourth
quarter Ben Simmons is really only guy
in that mix that can be that player and
as great as his I think a great player
he has not become that player at this
point so that's what I'm walking for
Philadelphia that's what could take them
to a Milwaukee like level and then out
west is it fair to say this may be
simple a Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated
this may sound oversimplifying it but
the the Clippers could be where the
Lakers are in terms of record if they
didn't load managed their way through
November and first half of December with
their two stars would you agree with
that assessment Chris you know maybe
just but you remember the start of the
season Paul George wasn't helping at all
that wasn't load management they were
load managing Hawaii and that's fine
well God clippers there's a one team in
the NBA they can afford to be a third or
fourth seed I mean it could cost them
and will cost them home court advantage
but it doesn't matter like they're that
good
like when Kauai and Paul George are at a
hundred percent and that group around
them is healthy and rested there it goes
the Lakers they don't need home court
advantage to win in the playoff to look
you know one way or the other if it
winds up being Clippers Lakers do not
get a home court advantage anyway their
home games it's not gonna be a home
court advantage but it won't Laker fans
and clipper fans that staples in that
series so I think that's one way to look
at that even if we get to the conference
final it's basically seven road games no
matter what you think so huh do you
think the Laker fans are gonna I don't
look that I don't know man I think
clipper fans would not sell their
tickets there's a ton of them in that
building for clipper games but well I
mean you know I mean you live out there
I know you know no I hope the next time
the next time the Clippers play you know
look on stuff up on game night you can
get tickets for like 10 bucks the last
time
with the Lakers I can't even remember
mm-hmm it's amazing the Lakers were
total dumpster fire as recent as
mid-june right I mean just watching the
finals obviously that they didn't even
make the playoffs and wondering about
how the lottery kind of went their way
and and even the the acquisition of
Anthony Davis it was being accused of
pálinka of not pulling the trigger at
the proper time and and costing them the
ability to maybe sign somebody else and
then Kauai doesn't come and they don't
get their super team and Vogel and Kidd
or are gonna be a total mess and now
here we are they're twenty four and four
I've never seen a general consensus of
this team doesn't know what it's doing
and the future is terrible to man
they're the best in the NBA it's amazing
yeah I mean every button that they've
pushed over the last let's say four
months has worked I mean I look uh it's
not Monday Morning Quarterback with me
I've long been a supporter of Frank
Vogel's I mean what he did in Indiana I
think people just forgot about I mean
that team was a mess when he took over
and he led them to back-to-back
Conference Finals while developing Paul
George and and others while
rehabilitating Roy Hibbert out there I
mean he is a really good coach but the
most surprising part was pelléas ability
to bring back the guys that work and
that worked for this group that being
Rondo and JaVale McGee taking the chance
on Dwight Howard I mean look I wrote
this in my column Dwight Howard two
years ago averaged 16 and 1/2 points and
12 rebounds while playing 81 games to
Hornets and the only offer he had then
was a one year plus offer from the
Washington Wizards even if you knew
nothing else about Dwight Howard that
says everything you need to know that a
guy averaging 16 and 12 at the center
position could only get one offer but he
has come in there and actually back up
his talk he said I'll be a role player I
don't care about numbers I'll come off
the bench and he's done exactly that the
first time in his career that's one
button that never would have expected to
be as impactful a couple of minutes left
with Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated
in the Honda insider report okay
Xion we just heard
from David Griffin in New Orleans that
they're getting close but there's still
no timetable due east do you think we
see him at all this year Chris yeah the
injury you know and I haven't checked in
in a couple of weeks but the injury is
not something that you would say shut it
down it's not a foot injury or the kind
of crack kneecap that Blake Griffin had
in his first year it it bothers them and
when you're looking at a guy like Zion
that is so top-heavy you want to make
sure that leg is a hundred percent right
where you send them back out there to do
all those explosive things but I would
be shocked if Zion shut it down this
year what it's done though Rich's turn
the pelicans from a team of you thought
might have a chance to make the playoffs
into one of those teams that other teams
look to raid before the trade deadline
you got to keep an eye on BIA Redick at
this point because he is one of the most
valuable trade ships out there prior to
Miss Edwards I mean if they if they make
the lottery again I mean Griffin puts
that tie on and they get the first
overall pick
I'm sure the the warriors the warriors
and Knicks will be just like what we
talking about here I mean it's amazing
the Warriors are even in that
conversation what do you think is the
future with Golden State I mean and how
can how remarkable and how the bottom
just keeps on sinking for this franchise
do you think we see curry again this
year Chris no I I don't you know it and
it'll get to the point in like mid-march
when they're just like screwing you know
they're not going to say anything now
but there's really no upside to bringing
stuff back what are you gonna do win a
couple more games and you know
potentially hurt your lottery chances
look the thing that scares people across
the league more than anything is the
idea that the owners at some point in
the offseason can package the Angela
Russell and a top five pick for
something good and you know I said the
top of this conversation rich that the
era of the super team and three-star
team is over for now that can bring it
back this chance you can package Russell
and a top five pick yes you're gonna get
something really really good in that mix
bike ooh what do you think I don't know
I mean I guess you kinda have to wait
until you see what happens mean you can
look up at Portland and and maybe see if
you can extract one of their guard
at MIT you know Danny Lotus from the
Oakland area I it's too early to tell
but that that's as good a package you
can put together for a trade proper just
because Russell could be an all-star
this year I don't know Billy to tell
right you have an all-star garden it's
early 20s and a top five pick you're not
gonna get a much better trade package
than that and last one for you Chris how
is David Stern do you know I mean what a
horrible horrible turn apparently his
health has taken of last week I'm
wondering what what can you tell me what
are you hearing yeah I mean nothing
specific just that when I talk to people
in the league office and people who talk
to people in the league office
there's just no over whelming amount of
concern you know about his condition
right now and and how he's gonna come
out of it I don't think anybody knows
for sure but very concerned I mean you
don't hear if there was optimism you'd
probably hear it and you people say it's
gonna be okay it's gonna be okay just
not hearing that this right now we need
a public statement or private one so I
think everybody at least ones that I've
talked to it's kind of hoping for the
best
yeah we all are I heard that I was so
crestfallen to hear that I mean talk
about a brilliant man and that that that
what might that what ails him is his
brain I mean of all things right I mean
this man's brain whatever what I mean
maybe maybe one of the most one of the
most impactful people in NBA history
when he sort of where the NBA was when
he started working for the league office
as a lawyer I mean they were still in
70s on tape delay Finals games kind of
how he has steered this lead into the
television monster that it is today with
some of the youngest demographics of any
of the four major sports I mean he
deserves a ton of credit for where the
safety NBA in right now thanks for the
call crests always enjoy our chats
immensely and and I hope our our
conversations get more frequent as the
season heats up thanks for the call hey
I'm rich you gotta that's a Chris Mannix
@s i Chris Mannix on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app